The last piece I want to talk about for research is intellectualy property.
There are great law firms who can give you tutorials.
There is plenty of stuff on the web.
But the types of intellectual property, shorthand IP, you want to think about are these.
There are 5. One is trademark.
Trademark means what can you protect as branding. Like the Nike swoosh.
The examples could be marks or logos or slogans.
Other type of intellectual property could be copyright.
An example is creative or authored works and expressions.
You can't copyright ideas, but you can copyright software or songs or movies or website content.
The other one is trade secrets.
Well I don't want to patent this because someone is going to read the patent.
They'll figure it out.
So you might have decided that you're going to protect it in a vault.
Just like the Coca Cola recipe is supposedly kept in a vault in Atlanta,
and it's non-public technology.
Also your customer lists might kind of fit in this category,
or some secret formulas necessary for our final element in your product.
Two things that startups run into all of the time are contracts or NDAs,
which stands for non-disclosure agreements.
You know what's protectable is in the contract, that is you specify it or somebody making
you sign it or offering you a contract or an NDA specifies it.
Examples are technology and business information.
By the way before we go forward, this is one point I want to mention.
Founders sometimes naively believe that they can protect their technology from investors
or potential investors by making investors sign a non-disclosure agreement.
That just doesn't happen, and it's a naive view of how to protect your technology.
My suggestion is, by the way, don't put your source code, your firmware, or your deep insight
in the first presentation.
Because you're never going to have somebody push a bag of money at you across the table
over a series of Powerpoint slides.
In fact if an investor is interested, and you are now in meeting 2, 3, or 4, and they say listen
for us to really proceed we need to have you open the hood and let us or a consultant
take a look, the next question to ask is well if we do that, and it meets these following criteria,
is there an investment or not?
If the answer is yes then you can make them, or at least require an NDA, because they have
gone down the path of interest with you and are serious.
The last piece of intellectual property is patent.
U.S. patent law has changed in some important ways in the last year.
If you were familiar with it it's nice to get updated with it again.
What's protectable are inventions.
Typical examples are new technologies.
You've invented something new. Some hardware, or algorithm, or software, etc.
Getting a patent is kind of important.